[Music]
in worst-ever news a worst submitted by
a Madeleine there are six nations that
stand out as the world's worst tourist i
want to guess i want to guess china
british you know merit good america sure
china British America French Ron there
may be oh I don't think the French
travel nobody the French travel no
because they just go to their own
oh you think all the European countries
like sort of stay in their own like
white whale in NY English British people
I just heard from a flight attendant
that it was British and another group
that I don't remember okay what British
stood out cuz all by what not even
Americans and they're like American
Psycho can we say Floridians flurry yes
Armenians I don't think I'm a nice
travel either the first one we're gonna
talk about a Glendale actually again you
don't leave Glendale
Cancun no no we went to Cancun we were
filled with a different Armenian
tourists holy like the the resorbs theta
and then when we were talking to them
they're like Jeremy nians love Mexico
cuz it looks similar probably well yeah
Casey thought I was Armenian what we
lived in Glendale during the time well
you look more person than are you about
to get a giant hate comments history
watch our music I know there's a
difference I just wanted to know what
the difference was I love a darker
mm-hmm
you got love of that tired tired I
noticed that cut your [ __ ] jokes that
we're being tired or [ __ ] tired or I
get a new one that's so bored it's
pretty new actually I'm [ __ ] sleepy we
haven't yeah right we haven't done it on
news that much actually they don't even
know the background behind a joke I
don't know we were doing it was doing JQ
party we're at the green room and then
Bart was asking like how come you know I
forgot the conversation started but I
pretty much that like I don't like
taking selfies and posting selfies and
then he was like why why don't you like
it and I'm like I don't know I just
don't like how I look like I always look
so tired like my eyes look droopy my
dark circles look really dark like I
just don't like the way I look in
selfies and then he was just like no
whatever and then the conversation
continued and since then
every time I post a photo on Instagram
he's like you look really tired you cats
you're like you're gonna be so upset
they look at Catholic type the backstory
of it dude Nikki will hear me [ __ ]
laughing out loud at like 12:00 and
midnight and she's like what are you
laughing at on my part [ __ ] it just so
that's half of it the other half is
they're trying to help her get over it
the biggest gay left got is some of your
most memorable favorite moments I'm
gonna post that I'm going to post this
and they're like oh it's cuz I look
tired I'm like you're gonna let you
being tired Trump the ya dope moment
that you climbed that mountain yes I
like she's probably think she looks
tired right now so for me I'm like okay
I did now I have to troll that because
that is ridiculous cuz I remember you
even told me you're like like so you
wouldn't even post a photo like Isaac
graduating or something and then I was
like I'll probably not if I'm tired of
him yeah but not me in it because I
don't like how I look in that photo and
that isn't me you look what because of
me not liking how I look in that photo
is just gonna ruin that moment for me or
that photo you're such a narcissist I am
yeah
I am I call all girls narcissists
because they care so much about that
looks more than the moments cuz we care
about to look so much - exactly I would
care about just as ass brother that's my
wife right like I cared the most about
that what are you talking about your ass
looks great in this picture exactly
people are so distracted by her ass she
does have a really nice yeah I have
Nicki's ass on recall in my brain I can
look at it any time you look at it right
now do you look at my ass yeah
especially her bent over butt-naked and
I can see both holes visualize
everything you guys totally visual
hey you look nice okay
anyway we're talking about Taurus you
guys home talk about
so I have a girl question but we could
go on we could keep going
we're not holding secrets in this group
that's why we're taking them all out
we'll talk about it there oh I like that
hey [ __ ] I got a lot of questions for
ladies of course I got a question for
the ladies okay say right now okay I'll
say the folio favorite for the podcast
okay don't forget it okay write it down
oh no all-girls podcast plus you called
you [ __ ] but not just like Asian mom
that's [ __ ] funny okay anyway so the
first the first nation five minutes 30
seconds Imus here our time is here
China's number one the worst we're not
saying whether or not this isn't any or
actually they do say not in any
particular order okay but low-key the
China's then I read it a me a group of
people that lets their kid [ __ ] on the
floor in the mall or whatever that's
that's really bad like that's China
yeah that's American kids to actually
show American kids [ __ ] on the floor
I've seen what I've seen kids like [ __ ]
their pants and then it gets all over
the floor that's China intentionally I
gotta go pee go ahead [ __ ] squat on a
foot and [ __ ] at an airport floor the
clothing that they make yeah [ __ ] um
they have these little shorts we're like
if you supply then it opens oh [ __ ] so
then the kids could just [ __ ] right
there and your clothes you have to UM
bunny no that's like a PG that's
supposed to be worn at home no I think
it's the China [ __ ] on the world
sit down the world like yeah you know
they they tend to have like meltdowns
and then they assault cabin crew and
then they vandalize archaeological site
yeah and then they urinate in public
places but they are doing some good in
the world because what they are the
saviors of the tourism industry in some
parts of the world so they're helping
pop of destinations like Egypt Turkey
Tunisia and like other Montford visiting
that's true because Americans will be
like oh no
Isis is happening and Chinese people
like I don't care they kind of killer
white people yeah not me and they're
fertilizing those dry ass areas where
the [ __ ] has to that's really true but
damn what a [ __ ] like oh my god it's
such a sacrifice though it's like I need
to survive I deal with these people
Chinese tourism man [ __ ] you it's like
do I sacrifices maybe I could deal with
a little bit of [ __ ] and piss on the
floor like if you're spending money I'll
just jump in the ocean swim somewhere
else you guys get the next one Americans
Americans so the people getting the
picture of the [ __ ] lady being held
off of a pool in Bali
I've actually swam in that pool and it's
like so the pool is like like goes down
a cliff okay easily it's like over a
cliff so the cat like picks his
girlfriend up and they're both like
Instagram people and like he's holding
her dangling off the balcony she's like
sticking her leg up in the air like like
this and it's just like [ __ ] these
people I hate these people they were
gonna fall or something no no it's just
like oh of course that's that's off well
Americans are on here but the next one
that we're gonna talk about is British
oh hey guys
yeah they're really polite friendly
considerate but as soon as they get a
few drinks and then they're you know
you're running and naked through the
street oh that's party yeah and then
they'll do the hotel balcony to pool
jump and it sounds like fine that's
American Jew - yeah for sure
and streaking is like an American
tradition yeah have you shaved it for
know we talked about like a guy running
on the baseball field naked [ __ ] yeah
but then again there's a lot of that
sucker a
I'm okay next party was invented can you
guys get the next one America what's the
next one
I just thought Americans British and
Chinese no cuz they're crazy Mexicans I
wish we were known as like world toys
but we don't get out much just throwing
stuff out there um Germans German same
thing because they're drunk too so they
they do have like you know their beer
bellies stuff and then they love their
speedos but yeah it's they'll drink what
do you mean beer belly stuff and love
there should be no suppose I mean um
because they had like a like just
they'll walk around in speedos but they
have a gigantic for your belly and that
makes a bed like what they're known for
their writing in here it's articles
where I'd gladly take that over a
Chinese tours taking a dump on my
sidewalk yeah it seems like it's like
Chinese tours and then like there's a
huge slope before the next white people
as far as their examples go saying that
Germans have turned to complaining into
an art form
yeah but if I can't understand them
Germans have a complaining culture
apparently I do anything about German
stereotypes well I said the finished
Henry says the transfer from the airport
includes cold towels soft drinks and
snacks they then they will insist on
cold towels soft drinks and snacks Oh
even if it means not noticing what's out
of the window only um the the German
stereotypes that I know is like straw
war - and pre I don't know anything
about after that well they also think
that their beer is the best beer ever
and it's not it's okay
have you had yeah okay I thought I was
really good wait so is Irish on there
then if drinking is a thing well no but
the next one is American alright
what's ours so it says that dress flops
out and complaining the stereotypical
American vacationer thinks everyone
should do things his way and if they
don't the answer is usually to throw
Fistful of Dollars around until they do
I'm paying for it but now the stereotype
is changing because now Americans are
becoming more respectful and stuff good
they're learning about the world
learning about like you know when in
Rome kind of stuff listen we're like 300
years old okay give us a break yeah it's
like I think American tourists are the
only types that get angry when people
don't speak English in a deer in another
country because in most countries they
do because do yeah it's crazy yeah I've
been all over and everybody speaks
English it's insane
number five here is Israelis Oh
renowned for being rude impatient noisy
and high on drugs
Raley's really what kind of drugs I've
never met one Israeli person only Jewish
people from Hollywood emerson's very
catty and like they start rumors and
children we're in Vegas those people
that were playing next to us at one of
the tables were Israeli oh I don't know
what do you know they were super cool Oh
like they didn't notice yeah there
should article or hobby blog dude I have
no idea also like to haggle a lot you
don't tuck in their shirt
it's like Brazilians they weren't really
bright colors lately
that's annoying they have these big
asses and they're always shaking it in
their defense many younger Israeli
backpackers have just completed military
service and travel in large happy groups
well tells of antisocial antics are
commonplace the conduct is argued
arguably no worse than that of other
young Globetrotters yeah I feel like
young backpacking military men is [ __ ]
up everywhere you know like the Marines
in Japan yeah so the last one is Russian
Russian Korres okay so they are the
unsmiling masters of the cultural faux
pas and practitioners of the no one
likes us we don't care approach to
travel who wrote this uh yeah it's just
very I've never encountered rude mean
Russians but maybe because I feel like
you've worked in like a touristy kind of
job though you probably encounter people
from like all over them I guess there's
not a lot to smile so they seem like
they're sad mm-hmm but they're very cold
though well I recently met a Russian
chicken she was so sociable and like so
nice and she smiled a lot and I'm like
wait you're not like this isn't them
stereotype that I built for you but she
was like yeah I mean I won't smile if
I'm in public and like you know just
with people that I don't know but
because you like I'm trying to get to
know you guys like I am like Russian
people are very sociable it's just like
if you're walking down the street with
strangers Russians are they Russian
energy smiling at every stranger too
much calories going this way must
survive all winter she also said that
it's not as cold as people think it's
just that in other parts of the world
they you don't you just don't know how
to layer up and you don't know how to
heat your home that's [ __ ] I've seen
pictures of [ __ ] like ice Lakes yeah
there's other parts of the world that
that happens too but she's just saying
bro she's got so much of it like there's
just so much ice in the country but dude
isn't it funny that you built up the
stereotype of like what a Russian person
has you met one and you're like yeah
she's so not Russian but really when you
think about it we're all the [ __ ]
same and it we're all too scared to
admit how boring we all are and we all
have to try to point out how different
we are because we think that's unique to
us no matter where you go everyone is
[ __ ] the same dude yep except I don't
know anybody sitting on the floor that's
true
[Music]
[Music]